good morning everyone we're going to
open the um the work session
on our interim study bills today
and we are going to first of all we're
going to
at this time we're going to start with
opening the work session on house bill
205 relative to the incarceration
under inspect suspended sentence
and as this is a work session on whether
or not to recommend future legislation
or not at this time i'll open it to
members if anyone has anything they'd
represent boardnet
thank you chair um
my understanding is that when we
discussed this uh in
the last time we discussed it
there was an amendment amendment that
was being offered that had been uh
worked on with the commissioner of
not that i'm aware of does anyone else
oh oh i'm sorry i didn't see you but did
this
who sponsored that amendment
representative chapero
is anyone here who signed on to that
amendment
can you tell us what the amendment did
uh inco in croatian
inquiry corporation
under a suspended sentence amen amend
rsa 651-20
i
to read as follows any person sentenced
to state prison for a minimum term of
six years or more
shall not bring a petition to suspend
that's been skipped
is within 12 months of serving
two-thirds sentence to state prison
for a minimum term of less than six
years shall not bring a petition to
suspend sentence until such a person has
served at least two-thirds of the
minimum sentence or the petition has
been authorized by the sentencing court
for the purposes of this sub paragraph
thank you representative um you're
welcome
absolutely took a second for
to remember what we were talking about
this goes back to the first year of our
term
there was some sort of technical problem
if i'm remembering correctly
we shelved it and then for the first
year we're planning to readdress it this
current year
but it we're told it was folded into a
senate piece of legislation is that is
that the
path that this took am i correct in that
i believe you are but i don't have the
the i don't have the bill of the senate
bill in front of me does anyone else
have any information on that
i i do have a note that uh
that it was to be incorporated into
sb-34
so that
based upon that the recommendation would
be not recommended for any future
legislation that's our options today
understood
would anyone like to make a motion at
this time
can we take a look and see guys
i'm not finding that i'm not finding
that bill is relative to the definition
of a controlled drug analog and
prohibiting the sailor possession of
synthetic urine and urine uh additives
and
let's just take a look and see if it's
maybe 134 oh okay yeah i'll have a look
mr mr chairman
yeah
go go ahead and
come up and
oh look at that
good morning honourable members of the
committee for the record my name is
helen hanks i'm the commissioner of the
department of corrections and um again
we did work collaboratively in 2021 to
put forward a bill that the department
could operate under um we certainly
defer to the legislature whether you
move forward with that the
opportunity it provides is that
reference to 12 months so that someone
could actually apply 12 months before
they're two-thirds and thus if the
sentencing judge and the prosecuting
attorney don't object and concur then
they could be released at that two-third
mark and then we were working to balance
the length of sentence um as well as
other concerns expressed by the victim
and survivor community so again we are
neutral just being a partner and trying
to bring forward a piece of legislation
that we could work and operationalize
as um
as this legislation was proposed were
you in favor of the way it was drafted
or did you
not uh in the in in the initial proposal
we were not in favor is the amendment
that was referenced that we worked on
and we could support that process
greg
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking the question
was there any resolve done by the senate
and have we already passed some
legislation on this at this point that
you know of that's a great question and
to my understanding nothing has passed
associated with this concept
thank you you're welcome um
go ahead
[Music]
thank you mr chair
uh
would this apply to anyone or is would
there be certain crimes that this would
not apply to
that is a great question and by nature
of our policy
we do have a list of crimes that are
excluded from participating and i don't
have that in front of me today
and i would have to look back to the
originating statute
but i don't believe it specifically
excludes it only requires the department
to create a policy from which to review
and make a recommendation to the
sentencing court prior to proceeding
thank you you're welcome
thank you i'm representative
[Music]
thank you thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um you said
you didn't support the bill originally i
think you said uh originally uh
the the change i saw
on the amendment which is not before us
uh changed from 18 months
within 18 months of serving two-thirds
to 12 months
is you didn't support the 18 but you did
support the 12 is that the big change
that was um thank you for that question
and that was the change and in fairness
without the two in front of me i believe
there was also some things around the
actual sentence length and when um and i
i could be confusing this with another
bill so i appreciate the question thank
you
thank you that thank you for your
testimony i'm going to ask mr head from
the
court to come up and give us a
good morning uh richard head government
affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch senator bill 134 which was an
omnibus bill does have the language with
the 12 months in it so part three of
that omnibus bill
uh says is within 12 months of serving
two-thirds of the minimum sentence so
that amendment did go through it did
pass and has been signed last session
very good that's all we need to know
thank you uh i'm going to recognize
anyone who'd like to make a motion
go ahead
i would uh make the motion that this is
not recommended future legislation as it
is already chaptered and signed into law
and it's been seconded by representative
i think we've had enough discussion this
time the
representative abbas
vice chairman roy
yes
representative burke
representative rhodes yes representative
green
clerk votes yes representative testerman
yes
representative true yes
representative pratt yes representative
representative marston
yes
representative o'hearn
representative bordnay yes
representative muse
representative newman
yes
representative bolden
representative conley yes
representative bradley
okay 14 yays
passes okay
okay
unanimous
no it's
not recommended for future legislation
okay at this time i'm going to close the
work session on hp 205 and open the work
session hb 253
requiring law enforcement officers to
use body cameras and establishing a
grant program to assist law enforcement
with agencies with purchase of body-worn
cameras
um i'll open by saying that
a bill did pass
hb i believe i mean sp 401 was a hp 401
that provided um
grant money for body cameras
and i believe that was signed into law
as well
does anyone have any more comments
they'd like to make on that
representative conley
thank you um
i just saw a post today from the state
police indicating that they are
rolling out their body-worn cameras and
cruiser cameras that's a great step
one part of this bill and i was the
prime sponsor although was
actually renee cushing's bill
was
to support departments around the state
that are not state police and to try to
create a funding mechanism
that gives them a way to offset those
costs i know dover has done it at it out
of its budget and it's very expensive
um
so
this bill clearly wasn't the solution
but i would hope that there maybe would
be a solution to create a pool of money
for local communities
to
to pay for these and to
actually the bill did
um
it was a sp or hb 401 i think it um the
bill that created the uh if you recall
representative burt was opposed to it
because it uh provided dash cams for the
d.o.t it also provided a pool of money
for body cameras for local
municipalities
in that case we are probably okay i
think so i agree
the only thing um that wasn't adopted
was the mandate portion of it um but um
personally i think that they're all
coming along in due course
anyone else wish to speak on this bill
seeing no one would anyone like to make
sorry about that uh
motion that
let's not move on to for future
legislation
i recommend it
seconded by representative wallace
at this point the clerk will call the
roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative burt
representative rhodes
representative greene
clark votes yes representative testament
yes
representative true yes
representative pratt yes representative
marston
yes representative harriet gathright yes
representative panalakis representative
o'hearn
representative boardney yes
representative muse yes representative
newman
yes
representative bolden
representative conley
representative bradley
representative espitia
14 yays zero nays
and the recommendation is adopted at
this time i'll close the work session on
hb 253 and open the work session hb526
relative to the fine for the sale of
i'll start by just saying that um
we
as a body produced
numerous pieces of legislation
regarding cannabis
and uh to the best of my knowledge none
of them made it out of the senate alive
let alone to the governor's desk
i anticipate
there will be no shortage of them in the
future i don't necessarily see a need
for this committee to recommend future
legislation i suspect it's going to
self-generate
um would anyone else like to comment or
talk about it representative bourdain
uh thank you chair um
i did look at the bill uh yesterday and
um
it seems like it's more of a first step
of
decriminalization of cannabis
commercialization
but there was one issue i had with it
and that is it
did not make
the
an age limit of 21 is an age limit of 18
and i'm
pretty sure that
like all other controlled substances we
are
doing the state alcohol and tobacco that
uh cannabis should be
uh at for the same
age
so i think that uh
possibly
that the bill that we offered
um
would be a great model for
future legislation
thank you anyone else like to talk
i respectfully disagree
and i will vote accordingly
okay
i recommend not to recommend
representative um i'm sorry you had
eliminating the fines for personal
possession seems to be one of the things
that a lot of people do actually agree
on
and in terms of the need for future
legislation
i think that there's definitely a need
to
to basically
completely decriminalize personal
possession
whether this is the approach to do it um
is is an entirely different question so
my question to the chair is are we
are we supporting
would we be supporting the approach in
this particular bill by doing that uh or
could we make a broader recommendation
for example that we support
eliminating penalties for personal
i don't think we can make a
recommendation broader than the actual
legislation itself because we would be
recommending this bill feature
legislation not not necessarily a policy
um
i think that we've had hours and hours
of discussion in this committee um
nowadays regarding this and we all
pretty much know where we stand on it um
i
i i agree that there that there needs to
be work done in that area and as i said
i suspect there'll be no shortage of
bills coming forward in the fall
and
i just in my opinion i don't think that
this committee as a as a policy body
needs to weigh into it
and pre-judge it before we actually get
bills in the fall
so um
i'm going to recognize representative
i recommend that we
not recommend this for future
legislation
seconded sorry go ahead represent here
gather did we already have a motion
no he just talked it that way all right
yes
representative welch
representative burt
representative rhodes yes representative
green
yes clerk votes yes representative
testament yes
representative marston
yes
representative harrick etherite
representative panolakis
representative o'hearn
representative bourdain
no
representative muse
yes
representative newman
representative bolden representative
conley
yes
representative bradley representative
espitia
12 eas
two nays
the motion carries the recommendation is
adopted
um with these i do not believe there's a
minority majority report i think it's
just the committee report
describing the um
the decision
if one is needed though i will get back
to uh representative true or
representative ordinary if we need a
minority report
so at this point i will close the work
session on hb 526 and open the work
session on hp 1105 relative to earn time
credits
this one
was a little more complicated
um so let's open up does anyone have
representative walsh
i think the subject matter is something
that's worth looking into
we started this process from several
years back
it's been somewhat successful
i i can't remember what was actually in
this bill
but i think the subject matter is worthy
of a future legislation
i don't know how we can do that but
ah thank you i
i believe the debate on this was
regarding courses that could be taken on
a tablet and whether or not
there was merit to that um i would like
one more time to quickly hear from the
commissioner if she doesn't mind
on where that stands and where she sees
again helen hanks commissioner of the
department of corrections for the record
um i believe that was the concern
brought forward by ms scitec that we
were using the tablet-based programs
we used those quite effectively during
covet quarantining our teachers and
educators use the learning management
systems within that to push course
materials from our granite state high
school and we also use them on the
courses referred to as the correctional
rehabilitation institute in the peace
education program in tandem
we have suspended those temporarily
because we had a technological glitch on
the
peace education and correctional
rehabilitation institute we're working
on the vendor on a new product
but we still continue to use those with
our granite state high school just like
individuals who take courses in the
community
can participate in their course online
when we have units under quarantine and
we do occasionally still have units
under quarantine
we'll figure covet is still here
if i may ask the
if you could there was there was some
discussion or comments made regarding
the ability of a prisoner or inmate to
take
numerous courses in one day
and and get good time for practically
just laying in bed for a day and taking
course of course can you give us a
little input as far as how rigorous
these are and
um whether that's a possibility
i mean i think someone could lay in bed
just like a college student lays man
takes their courses that's quite a
description but um
i go back to the individuals who are
incarcerated have a fifth on average a
fifth grade education level so if the
course materials are so high that they
can't understand them then there's no
point in delivering the materials so for
you or i the rigor would not be as
rigorous but for someone with a fifth
grade education they do
do need to take time to go through them
and sometimes don't understand some of
the words
the peace education program itself takes
five hours and the other correctional
rehabilitation institute courses take
differing amounts of time it was those
in combination not separately that would
have awarded people earn time credit
we deliver and provide earn time credit
in numerous other areas of the agency as
prescribed by law and i think that also
has meaning here
people's meaningful participation in
mental health treatment is actually one
of the number one areas people remit for
earn time credit and then obviously with
the federal change in the pell grant
will have increased opportunities
through post-secondary education as well
as attaining their high school diploma
their high school equivalency and other
career and technical education sets to
earn earn time credit and as the
legislature outlined it for attaining
your high school diploma you actually
receive 120 days
and then you receive 60 days for
additional vocational programming as
outlined in law and then our family
connection center program as well
thank you i i didn't mean to um besmirch
the um
the position of the inmate when they
were actually taking the course i just
it was the vision that was being
portrayed it looks shocking when you say
it that way yeah when i think about
someone going to college absolutely
young people in my family i don't think
the legislature is concerned with their
uh
vertical or horizontal position but
what the concern was is not necessarily
the academic rigor as far as we would be
concerned because i do believe it should
be appropriate to the education
um but the amount of time that they had
to invest was was more the concern like
they couldn't just burn through these
like four or five a day or something
like that
i think that they could on the
correctional rebate rehabilitation
institute again they're individuals who
have almost uh 10 to 11 hours a day
where they could be engaged for that
amount of time
um but i did put a pause on those
and
in
respect the information that had already
come to me prior to this legislation
moving forward to evaluate them as
the legislature asked me to under the
statute
and as far as that opportunity i would
hasten to say if we remove the tablet as
an opportunity to deliver our high
school programming through the learning
management system it would actually slow
the technological progress of the
department of corrections in trying to
deliver
education
i tend to agree i don't think we should
be limiting possibilities for anybody
this particular ability that's in front
of us
um did
did you or other people
have do work on this and and come up
with some solutions to that and and
obviously this bill
would need to be amended to make it the
way that it needed to be to make sure
they were getting the education getting
it properly with the proper constraints
and rules and regulations
my my question just relies it goes to
my confusion with kind of this process
because it's the first time that i that
i've been involved with where we the
recommended
to have a bill be recommended to go
forward
and obviously there is someone could
write a whole new bill and it could go
forward
in your experience
with how it affected the corrections
department
is it
is it more beneficial or efficient to
recommend something like a bill like
this for legislation
as opposed to someone starting from
scratch and trying to rewrite the bill i
suppose they could copy this bill and
submit it but just just your experience
and thoughts on that
i thank you for that question and i've
had the fortunate experience with being
with the agency since the inception of
runtime credit and the changes that have
moved forward since then i don't believe
that section of law needs adjustment um
so i wouldn't recommend changes to their
own time credit law i think the
department manages it quite efficiently
and
i respect the feedback that was provided
but i don't think it would have taken
legislation to ask the department to
look at an area of concern we would have
representative conley
thank you mr chairman commissioner you
addressed just there the question that i
had is
um
does the feedback you've received
give you guidance that you can move
forward with to address any concerns and
it sounds like with the pause you're
already doing so that would negate the
need for future legislation or at least
a recommendation from this committee i
would agree and in addition to we also
created an earn time credit review
committee so individuals who wanted to
remit other programming not identified
in law or specifically in policy that it
gets reviewed by a multi-disciplinary
corrections committee before it comes
okay oh representative muse
thank you
during during testimony one of the
things that we heard was that there are
some issues around uh the notification
process when people take these courses
um so the impression that i got um i
think from hearing um i think there was
a uh some uh someone uh from the from
the coalition who was here there's an
issue with uh victims being continually
notified when these when these uh
courses are are completed how does that
work do you
have i know you were here for that
testimony has anything changed about
your process do you
maybe
notify
victims after four or five completions
or when they've actually accumulated
time to have a sentence reduction or is
this a process where people are just
continually getting disturbing emails
uh represent muse that's a great
question so we're working and we
actually have a new administrator of
victim services unfortunately our
previous one got a really great
opportunity we couldn't salvage it but
we have a new
great human being in that capacity we're
working on
we're still working on how do we try to
bundle those um and uh
and a person
we're also moving forward with the vine
electronic notification system so it's a
self-service model for someone who wants
victim notification to choose when they
want to know
so i think those two things will help
i do think there was an expressed
concern for people who were sentenced
prior to the inception of the law
in 2014 attorney head might have that
date right
going forward and still asking for this
opportunity and the question i asked was
is there some restriction you could put
that if it wasn't on your minimus then
don't ask again but i i'm not the
judiciary so i could be interfering
people's due process privilege here
rhodes
thank you mr chairman so
just to clarify could you
could you clarify whether or not the
the victims assistance unit is on on
this committee or is not on this
committee
so the victim
services bureau within our agency
is not on the committee to review earn
time credit but is part of the process
that if someone is awarded earn time
credit that we make our statutory
notification
and we're being responsive to those
concerns trying to see if we can
bundle how that happens so they don't
get you know four or five notifications
through the course of six months but
they get one notification that these
four events happened
because it changes someone's sentence
structure
thank you um
it sounds to me like the um like the
commissioner and the department has a
good handle on this and they've taken
the feedback from the um although i have
uh just forgot again that representative
gathright wanted to ask a question
sorry mike that
well it's a comment i think um i had a
note here that um
when we had the hearing that
commissioner hanks had testified
and she was against the bill
and she personally review all the
credits and releases recommend you know
for everyone that comes before him and
um which i thought was really
exceptionally great that something like
that even occurs that there's another
eye that's really looking at everyone
that wants the burn time credits and
things of that nature so for me i don't
i don't believe that this is necessary
and should be recommended
uh thank you is that a motion
representative catherine absolutely and
what would that motion be my motion
that hb 1105 is not recommended
for
further
release
seconded by uh representative wallace
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burke representative
rhodes
yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative testament
yes representative true
yes
representative pratt
representative marston
yes representative harry gathright yes
representative panelakis representative
o'hearn representative bordenay
yes
representative muse
representative newman
yes
representative bolden representative
conley
yes representative bradley
representative espitia
14 yeas zero nays the motion carries and
the recommendation is not recommended
for future legislation at this point i
will close the public hearing on hb 1105
and open the public hearing on hp 1127
relative to the posthumous exonerations
and annulments
and this bill if i recall was um
also one from
representative cushing and it had to do
with
i believe someone who was wrongly
accused of witchcraft in the
i believe that there were some questions
with regard to whether someone would
have standing
to bring
such a motion to the court
and i also believe that we discussed
that the executive
has the
culinary power to grant pardons and
actually correct this record
much easier than than a court process
would um so anyone have any comments or
wish to discuss this
representative welch
yes realizing that whatever we vote
today isn't going to
make any difference once the elections
take place and new people come in
i think
this should not be recommended because
the bill that we heard
the senate came from the bay state
so
it's nothing we could have done about it
i would
be recognized for a motion
that this not be recommended for future
legislation i'm going to uh hold that on
and let anyone else who wishes to speak
talk first representative gathering
i just want to mention that we verified
that
the judge that made the decision in the
case was new hampshire and not
massachusetts because that was brought
up in the hearing and
you can go online you can see all the
documentation and everything was handled
in new hampshire
was it um
was it not at the time though still part
of massachusetts i believe that's not
what it says
it says it was new hampshire
okay well i i guess that's really
neither here nor there as far as whether
or not we
decide to move forward representatives
yes i i just wanted to point out that
this isn't the first time this has come
up in the legislature with hb2 last year
one of the things that we did as a body
was that we basically
forgave
the people who violated the governor's
cove executive orders
now the governor signed the bill and
that's why it went into law
but if we were to uh
to pass a bill like this in the
legislature the governor would also be
required to sign it into law before it
becomes law
so
while the powers of pardoning are
reserved for the governor i went through
the law pretty pretty carefully the
governor and the executive council
are the folks who are in charge of
pardons what we're talking about here
isn't the pardon of a person um who is
still alive
um we're talking about uh creating an
injustice and or i'm sorry we're talking
about fixing an injustice uh
and
this is something that that is within
our power um
i i do think that this is a bill uh that
we should
that we should consider again because i
mean part of
i think one of the reasons why a lot of
us here are here is to make sure that
um
that wherever we can we can we can fix
injustice when we see it and if you look
at these particular cases
having people convicted of witchcraft
and and people
um unfairly uh
accused of crimes that when we look back
you know this there's a lot of doubt
about um
you know who was actually in error here
was it was it the person who was uh
accused of the crime or was it some of
the
uh officials in government who went
after that person
so um
i don't think that this thing is is
necessarily cut and dry
but i would like to see it come back in
represent testimony
what worries me about this one it's a
lot like
tearing down statues that we seem to be
in vogue right now of people who
possibly had some
long past
what we think to be
a
honoris type of
of activity and you know
things that happened in the past
are not good or bad i have a
have
rallies my wife were incarcerated in in
in world war ii
we're not looking
to
basically
condemn
president roosevelt for having passed a
law
it happened
it's over with
thank you
um
i'll say this um
it's obvious from the record that
miss goody was um wrongfully accused and
sentenced
and we cannot bind a futurist
legislature
um
but we could we can make a
recommendation as a committee that
while this would not erase or change
history what it would do is is
acknowledge
the current body's um
recognition of a
of a past wrong
um so i i
i don't see the harm in
recommending it for future legislation
and if the next body comes in and
decides to do so but i think as a policy
statement from this committee
it would be a good move for us to
recognize that there was an injustice
done here
and it wouldn't change history it would
still be there as a matter of fact it
would add to the history that we
actually
saw and recognized and and and
wanted to correct it
so i would um recognize representative
i move that hb 1127 be recommended for
second anybody
seconded by representative ordinary
vice chairman roy
i vote yes
representative welch
yes reluctantly
representative burt
representative rhodes yes
representative greene
no
clerk votes yes
representative testament no
representative pratt
no
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright yes
representative panelakis representative
o'hearn
representative bordenay
yes representative muse
yes representative newman
yes
representative bolden
representative conley yes
representative bradley representative
espitia
10 years four nays
it's recommended and and for the record
i would just like to um
add that i i support this also in part
because of the many years of hard work
that uh the late representative cushing
and many attempts he made to
to right this wrong and that's part of
the reason i supported this spell so in
his honor
um at this point i will close the public
hearing hp uh what is it 1105
and open the public hearing excuse me
the work session on hb 1232
reducing the penalty for first time drug
possession and repealing certain
mandatory minimum sentences
um
i'm going to say the same thing i said
on the previous
marijuana bill
as a committee i don't think we should
be
making recommendations on things that
are sure to come before us
in the fall and pre-judging i think we
should just wait and see what comes to
us
and hear the pills um as they come on
their own merits
i think enough bills have come out of
this committee
and our position has been pretty clear
on them and they just haven't seemed to
get any traction so i'm recommending
that we
just wait and see what comes to us and
see deal with it as it gets here anyone
is that our recommendation i'll second
it
i can as chair um representative
casey
mr chairman just uh i agree that this
will be back i'm sure um
the fact that this committee has
recommended
uh at least one version of this bill um
near unanimously in the first year of
our term
suggests
we support the concept and and should
give it that nudge
um moving forward i know that this is
not the bill
uh that left the committee in that way
but there's different ways up the
mountain and i think we're gonna have to
come up with a new approach
seeing as the other ones have failed but
as a concept i think it's something that
the committee supports and we should
give it a recommendation of passage
this bit about first offense
it's the first defense they were caught
at if anybody believes the people who
are picked up on a first offense of
something
it's the first time they've used drugs
they're using them to i just
representative walsh
yes this bill
the the first offense drug possession i
i don't
i don't support at all but repealing
some of the mandatory minimum sentences
i've worked on that before and i think
sometimes
that would be a good thing so i have
mixed feelings about that particular
bill and
i think if we were
to recommend this for future legislation
it kind of gives a signal that we would
approve of it
so i would
representative rhodes
think i echo a lot of what
representative welch is saying and i i
think one of the things that we need to
remember is
a lot of times
you know the the
these these charges are played down so
it tends to get watered down in what was
actually
what the person was arrested for and
what they may or may not have actually
been
charged with and i think that's
something we need that we need to
consider
thank you mr chair
um
i think we have judges because they
judge things because they take things in
front of them and consider all the
circumstances
i think the mandatory minimums tie the
hands of judges in some cases
fairly and unnecessarily with the
results of the person that's charged
so i'm opposed to mandatory minimum
sentences so therefore i won't i
think that we need to recommend this
bill for
future
consideration representative green
i think it gives the people a false
sensation that if they get a me a light
sentence for the first pers first time
possession that they're going to get a
light sentence from thereon too so
would you like to make a motion
i make a motion to itl
you mean not recommended for future
legislation
yes any one second
representative pratt seconds oh second
yeah i'll read it go ahead um
hb uh 1232 uh reducing the penalty for
first offense drug possession or
repealing certain mandatory minimum
sentences the motion on the floor is not
recommended for future legislation
and the vote is to you
yeah he would normally go last so that's
correct
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch
yes
representative burt representative
rhodes yes
representative greene yes
clark votes yes representative testament
yes
representative true nay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
yes
representative panolakis representative
o'hearn
representative bourdain
yes
representative bolden
representative bradley
representative espitia
chairman abbas
uh okay it's back uh the motion carries
not recommended for future legislation
and
i will at this time close the work
session on hb
12 32 and
and open the work session on hp 1281.
would the chair like to take over or
okay we will continue
relative to access to firearms
confiscated from a person who is subject
to a protective order um i'll open by
saying this was actually my bill
um it was designed it was brought
forward at the request of a constituent
allow people who had restraining orders
to dispose of their firearms
in a more cost effective manner than
currently exist
however after speaking with
representatives from the domestic
violence coalition
um i actually recommended that my own
bill be sent to interim study
and i think there possibly could be some
room to work and do something on it but
at this time it's in my opinion
um not specific enough to recommend for
future legislation until i have or
whoever would like to speak with
and work with the domestic violence
coalition but at this point out of
respect for their concerns
um i would recommend that we not
recommend this for future legislation
would anyone else like to speak
representative ordnae
uh thank you mr chairman um
i've been thinking about this bill
because i understand that uh
uh having your web your firearms uh kept
by
law enforcement it can be an expensive
operation
and the uh the problem of
having just anybody
uh
monitored or somebody's or keeps
somebody's firearms
is
a problematic as well because
how can they be trusted not to let their
friend borrow their firearm
but
on the way on the drive over this
morning i said who
how
could we do this
and
it would
have to be someone that is licensed or
bonded
that
they are
they ready are
familiar with firearms and i'm thinking
that a lot of people belong to
gun ranges that gun reagents would be a
be a keeper of firearms that have been
uh sequestered
and i appreciate the thought you put
into that and i'd be happy to discuss it
with you over the off-season
representative welch
yes when ed brown over in the
it was plainsville when he was arrested
he had 35 firearms
and they were put in the custody of
riley's gun shop
now it still cost them for the storage
but the complaint
originally that we had about this
situation was if they're stored at the
police stations there's no guarantee
they're going to not rush and so forth
and some of these guns are kind of
expensive
so
it's a situation that needs to have an
i'm looking forward okay
i uh i i tend to agree with you i think
that the but the subject matter this is
so delicate that it needs to be worked
on with a scalpel and it's too um
it's too complicated to for a blanket
recommendation in my opinion of future
legislation at this point however i will
be bringing something forward after
consulting with all the interested
stakeholders
representative marston
[Music]
thank you mr chairman
my only question in this bill
is it's talking about a relative access
to firearms
so
is that saying that we confiscated them
but you can have an access to them
the intent was so that a relative
could
pick up the firearms for you
and either hold them or dispose of them
but you would not have access to them
but as i said it it definitely needs
representative abbas
thank you mr chairman
so i what i understood too is
there's nothing preventing anyone from
selling or transferring title
if the in the custody of law enforcement
it can still be done unless it's
you know evidence of a crime but if it's
just simply because of a
in a domestic violence restraining order
they're not going to be
prohibited from selling them
but for any issues involving domestic
violence that everyone knows and
representative rory and i we were at
that meeting
there was a task force that came out and
they put the court system published it's
150 pages i recommend everyone take a
look at it
i'll have the
committee assistant email copy that to
everyone
it was really comprehensive so any
issues on that subject including this
you know i would kind of focus on what
the task force recommendations were
doesn't mean we have to follow them but
just keep put that into consideration
agreed and that was also part of my
very high uh
storage charges by the time
yeah agreed that was part of my fear and
the constituents fear is that we would
end up with a system such as that
where once they were gone you may as
well forget them and also um my intent
was so that
the defendant would actually have access
to sell them
should he require or she require
the funds to pay for their council
moving forward that's the liquid assets
tied up so there is a lot of angles to
look at this and like i said i think it
will require some definite research
um
i can't make a motion with anyone else
like to make a motion representative
walsh
i make a motion that house bill 1281 not
be recommended for legis future
legislation
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt
representative rhodes
representative greene
clark votes yes representative testament
representative true yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright yes
representative panlakis representative
o'hearn
representative bordenay yes
representative muse yes representative
newman yes
representative bolden representative
conley
representative bradley representative
espitia
representative abbas
chair votes yes
to zip
the recommendation of not recommended
for future legislation is adopted
i hereby close the work session hp 1281
open the work session on hsb 292
um i'll also address this one this
should be really quick
this was brought forward at the request
of parole probation
as they were having difficulty
coordinating notifications
to them if if one of their parolees or
probationers were arrested
based on my previous law enforcement
experience i knew that there was an
electronic way to do this much quicker i
met with the state police parole
probation and the i.t folks and they
actually were able to figure out a
simple um
hopefully simple fix
whereby if someone
runs the record arrests
or has any interaction
with a parolee or probation officer
that's entered into the computer system
the probation or parole would be
automatically notified immediately so
when they came into work the next day
they would have a notice that their
person was run by somebody that they
could follow up
so
based on that
at the request of probation and parole
i would recommend that we do not
move forward with future legislation on
representative marston
thank you mr chairman is is this the
possibility though that this will come
forward or has it been already done
something because of the senate and
going through the whole process
actually it was accomplished without
legislation um they were able to work
with the existing
existing system they had and connected
everybody so it's no longer an issue so
they don't they don't need legislation
would someone like to make a motion for
representative martin
i'll motion that the uh sb 98 292 be not
representative here at gathering seconds
clerical
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch yes representative
byrd representative rhodes yes
representative greene yes clark votes
yes
representative testament representative
true
yes
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes representative harriet gathright yes
representative panolakis representative
o'hearn representative bordenay yes
representative muse yes representative
newman
yes
representative bolden
representative conley
representative bradley
all right cheer votes yes
15 to zero
and the recommendation of not
recommending future legislation is
adopted and i hereby close the work
session on hb 292 i'd like to thank
everyone for a great uh couple years and
um i will let the representative uh
and i was gonna uh give everybody an
early christmas present i'm going to go
ahead and do all the uh
reports
for this
so
everyone enjoy your summer and uh good
luck in all your races
[Music]
well
i say a couple of words you know i'm
leaving i'm not coming back
i will be back on occasion i think to
testify on on
some bills
but i was the first chairman when this
committee was first formed
and
the work is important
buckle down and and dig into these bills
as we get them some of them are simple
some of them
as the vice chairman has indicated very
complicated
so i wish you all well
and uh
i'll see you on veto day
and i will not hesitate to pick your
brain next year
thank you very much for your service and
[Applause]